[Música]
todos los días tenemos muchas ideas de
hecho cientos de ellas esas ideas son
relativas y bueno tenemos ideas que van
desde y que voy a desayunar este día oa
lo mejor alguien se pregunta y si
estudio una ingeniería o si estudió una
licenciatura oa la mejor ideas un
poquito más complicadas como y si le
pido un aumento a mi jefe o si cambio de
trabajo o incluso aquellas ideas como
y si invito a salir a la chica que me
gusta hoy
este es más complicada verdad
bueno pues
cuando tenemos ideas que realmente nos
apasionan que realmente queremos hacer
incluso las imaginamos imaginamos
acercándonos a esa chica y diciéndole
oye quieres ir a cenar conmigo o a lo
mejor alguien imagina escribiendo un
libro y se ve presentándolo y
exponiéndolo ante muchas personas e
imagina a la gente diciéndole sí y todo
el mundo quiere su autógrafo y el libro
se convierte un best seller pero resulta
que cuando estamos imaginando esas
fabulosas ideas hay una voz interna en
nuestra cabeza que nos dice oye pero tú
no eres muy bueno escribiendo
a veces se te pasa algunos acentos no
creo que puedas escribir un libro o
incluso nos dice pero si esa chica que
tanto te gusta ni siquiera le hablas
y es que esa voz que escuchamos en
nuestra cabeza pensamos que es la voz de
la voz de la razón porque se rige por
normas absolutas que están preconcebidas
en nuestra mente
y es que muchas personas creen que por
más que tengas la idea más innovadora
con un modelo de negocios increíble o
por más que se te haya ocurrido una idea
para resolver el calentamiento global
pues no va a afectar la realidad porque
sigue siendo una idea y de eso hay que
modificar la realidad pues es muy
complicado
pero hay algo que estas personas no ven
algo que no se dan cuenta imaginemos que
aquí mismo hay alguien que dice yo tengo
la idea de ir a estudiar al extranjero
pero sé que es muy complicado tengo que
aprender perfectamente otro idioma
es muy costoso además y el proceso es
exhaustivo por lo tanto ir a estudiar al
extranjero es algo casi imposible
pero tenemos otra persona que es del
mismo lugar con la misma edad y que
incluso está estudiando lo mismo está en
igual condiciones y ella dice yo tengo
la idea de ir a estudiar al extranjero y
sé que muchas universidades en europa
ofrecen becas para que alumnos puedan
asistir a ellas y que con así ofrece
también muchas oportunidades para poder
ir a estudiar a una universidad entonces
esta segunda persona y no por su mapa
mental y no su forma de pensamiento y
ahora sabe que es posible hacerlo
entonces las ideas son relativas
realmente las ideas pueden afectar la
realidad y dependen solamente de
nosotros mismos de lo que está en
nuestra mente
bueno déjenme contarles que en agosto
del 2010 era mi primer semestre en la
universidad recuerdo que había una
materia en la que se llamaba redacción y
expresión oral o expresión verbal bueno
en realidad no recuerdo también y en esa
materia
teníamos un proyecto final el cual tenía
que ser armar un pequeño congreso en
este congreso pues teníamos que diseñar
el programa y obviamente dar pequeñas
charlas para que se llevara a cabo el
evento
recuerdo bien eso sí lo recuerdo muy
bien que de pronto tuve una idea por mi
mente
y dije y si yo doy una de esas charlas
de inmediato la voz interior de la razón
me dijo oye pero nunca has hecho nada
así y no eres muy bueno hablando en
público
pero en ese preciso instante en ese
momento que estaba escuchando esa voz
que me decía que no podía que realmente
era algo muy complicado y que no tenía
la experiencia para hacerlo me di cuenta
de una cosa me di cuenta que durante
todo el semestre nos habíamos preparado
para realizarlo me di cuenta que había
adquirido algunas habilidades que me
permitían ya poder dar esta pequeña
charla e incluso ya tenía un tema
preparado que había desarrollado durante
esta materia
y pues sin más me apunté me puse en el
programa y ya quedó listo el problema
fue un día antes del evento
estaba yo en la cama no podía dormir
solamente pensaba y si hago el ridículo
y si se me olvida y qué pasa si
no puedo avanzar en la charla que voy a
hacer
y bueno pues al otro día me desperté me
preparé
llegué a la escuela me senté en uno de
los lugares de esta enfrente tenía las
manos sudando recuerdo que el corazón se
me salía pensaba y si me voy a esconder
a otro lugar
pero de pronto escuché mi nombre y pues
me levanté y camine hacia el escenario
el piso se movía incluso y así pues
llegué al frente del escenario y comencé
a hablar
me enfoqué en transmitir aquello que
quería comunicarles a la pequeña
audiencia
y me di cuenta que en realidad esa
experiencia era muy agradable porque
había muchas personas ahí escuchando más
dispuestas a escuchar lo que tú les ibas
a decir dispuestas a escuchar tus ideas
y más allá de ser un problema una
dificultad es realmente una oportunidad
y bueno así fue como fue la primera vez
que me subí a un escenario y pues
realmente aprendí que si las ideas son
relativas y las ideas pueden cambiar la
realidad y pueden hacer que tú logres
cosas que no imaginabas y bueno tal vez
algunos de ustedes estarán preguntando y
por qué es el nombre de la charla como
esta
y bueno es así porque yo encuentro una
relación fascinante de las ideas con la
teoría de la relatividad
y les voy a explicar un porqué primero
debo advertirles que soy ingeniero pero
no soy físico así es que les voy a
explicar como yo lo entiendo así es que
no se aceptan reclamos de proyecciones
por ahora al menos bueno pues resulta
que en 1620 galileo galilei establece
las bases de la física
y dice que el universo está en constante
movimiento por lo tanto el movimiento es
relativo ya que para que sea válido
alguno de estos movimientos del universo
tiene que ser comparado con otro objeto
en el mismo universo entonces todo es
relativo se tiene que estar comparando
para que realmente aparecimos este
movimiento y todo iba bien hasta que en
1905 llega un señor que se llama albert
eisntein
y dice que no que el universo se rige
bajo una constante que es absoluta esta
constante es la velocidad de la luz y
resulta que que él dice que nada puede
ir más rápido que la velocidad de la luz
y que solamente está constante es la que
va a permanecer en el universo y de
pronto se empiezan a generar muchas
reglas muchas normas en base a esta
constante absoluta normas que iban desde
si una persona nunca ha hablado en
público pues no puede dar una
conferencia si una persona no tiene una
ortografía perfecta y no escribe muy
bien no puede escribir un libro
si una persona tiene la idea de estudiar
en el extranjero pues no la puede hacer
normas de este tipo
pero entonces en 1916 otra vez viene
einstein y dice saben que siempre no
y establece la teoría general de la
relatividad
en esta teoría el estipula que si por
alguna razón un objeto logra romper esta
constante absoluta estas normas
establecidas como absolutas y mediante
la adquisición de capacidades y
habilidades vence esta constante
puede cambiar la realidad puede deformar
el tiempo y el espacio
y puede generar cosas increíbles y
completamente nuevas que nunca antes la
imagen la humanidad había pensado y
entonces es así como una persona que
nunca antes había hablado en público de
hecho que ni siquiera era tan bueno
expresándose con amigos y familiares
tiene la posibilidad de cambiar su
realidad y afectar su entorno
tiene la oportunidad
de poder participar en eventos
internacionales tiene la oportunidad de
que sea invitado a dar un curso de
emprendimiento en perú y de vez en
cuando poder dar algunas charlas en
universidades para compartir sus ideas
ante alumnos
y bueno entonces las ideas no son
absolutas las ideas dependen de ti
las ideas pueden cambiar tu realidad
pueden cambiar la realidad pero solo
y lograr adquirir atributos
características y algunas
algunos beneficios que te puedan ayudar
a vencer las reglas absolutas que hay
las reglas que tenemos aquellas normas
que están estipuladas en la sociedad y
en nuestras creencias por pues porque
simplemente así está ni siquiera sabemos
por qué realmente se puede cambiar la
realidad y puedes deformar el espacio y
el tiempo
y ya para terminar nada más déjenme
contarles una idea que tuve hace algún
tiempo esta idea pues parecía complicada
y muy distante
la idea era
y si algún día de hoy una charla te
[Aplausos]
[Música]